his Home Secretary says the Asylum
system is broken
who broke it
well Mr Speaker let's let's just we can
look at the record on migration let's
look at it what did what did
what what did we on this side of the
house do we gave the British people a
referendum on brexit
we we delivered we delivered brexit we
ended the free movement of people Mr
Speaker that's our record on migration
policy it's not something The Honorable
gentleman supported he opposed it at
every turn and it's not what the British
people want
[Applause]
[Music]
no one wants open borders on this side
of the house they've lost control of the
borders on their side of the house
speaker
four four prime ministers in five years
it's the same old same old he stands
there and tries to pass the blame if the
Asylum system is broken and his lot have
been in power for 12 years how can it be
anyone's fault but theirs
[Applause]
Mr Speaker people rightly want to see us
getting a grip of migration in our
borders oh look
let's look at the record
let's look at the record the right
normal gentleman he voted against the
nationality and borders bill
[Applause]
the free movement of people look border
control border control is a serious
complex issue but not only does the
party opposite not have a plan they have
opposed every single measure we have
taken to solve the problem you can't
attack a plan if you don't have a plan
foreign
against it because we said it wouldn't
work and it hasn't worked he he says
he's getting a grip he's got a plan so
let's have a look at that plan the
Rwanda deal was launched in April it
cost the taxpayer 140 million pounds and
Rising the number of people deported to
Rwanda is zero since then 30 000 people
have crossed the channel in small bloat
it's not working is it he hasn't got a
grip
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we on this side of the house
are clear that we want to defend our
borders when the shadow Home Secretary
this weekend was asked she couldn't
answer a simple question if the party
opposite was in favor of higher or lower
migration
I when it comes to tackling our
migration reducing migration we are on
the same page that party's policy it's a
blank page Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker blame others deflect attack
on something else so much the new age of
accountability
of all the people who arrived in small
boats last year how many Asylum claims
have been processed
we do need we do need
Mr Speaker not enough is the answer very
straightforwardly
and that's what we're going to fix but
The Honorable The Honorable gentleman
raises this question what do we do we've
increased the number of processing
officials by 80 we are putting an extra
500 more by next march but if he really
if he really was serious about fixing
this problem then he would acknowledge
that we do need to tackle the issue of
people putting Furious
Furious claims spurious repeated last
minute claims to frustrate the process
That's How we'll tackle the system so
why then did he vote against the
nationality and borders act which deals
with it
Mr Speaker he says he says not enough
you can say that again
it's four percent four four percent of
people arriving in small boats last year
had their Asylum claim processed
according to the book is the Home
Secretary has a better chance of
becoming the next story leader than she
has a processing and Asylum claim in a
year
hahaha
and he talks about numbers they're only
taking half the number of Asylum
decisions that they're used to that's
why the system is broken 4
000 people at the manston Air Force Base
massively overcrowded all sorts of
diseases breaking out so did the Home
Secretary receive legal advice that she
should move people out yes or no prime
minister
Mr Speaker that the right honorable
gentleman is very fond of reminding us
that he used to be the former director
of public prosecution so he knows the
government's policy on commenting on
legal advice but what I can say is a
significant action that the Home
Secretary has taken to fix the issue
since September 30 more hotels with four
and a half thousand new beds appointing
a senior General to control the
situation at manston and indeed
increasing the number of staff there by
almost a half Mr Speaker these are
significant steps to demonstrate that we
are getting a grip of this system but
this is a serious and escalating problem
we will make sure that we control our
borders and we will always do it fairly
and compassionately because that's the
right thing
Mr Speaker he talks about my time as
director of public prosecutions I
prosecuted people's Smugglers he can't
even get an asylum claim process
I think the answer to the question
whether Home Secretary received legal
advice to move people out of Marsden is
yes he just hasn't got the guts to say
it we
he did a grubby deal with her putting
her in charge of Britain's security just
so he could Dodge an election
she's broken the ministerial code lost
control of a refugee Center and put our
security at risk she did get one thing
right she finally admitted that the toys
have broken the Asylum system criminal
gangs running amok thousands crossing
the channel in small boats every week
hardly any claims process so why doesn't
he get a proper Home Secretary scrap the
Rwanda gimmick Crackdown on smuggling
gangs in the Small Boat Crossings speed
up Asylum claims and agree an
international deal on Revenue start
governing Watson gets a group
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
that the right the right honor all
gentle front rules let me just calm it
down a little I do want to hear the
replies you're covering your mouth's not
helpful to me or you come on prime
minister
Mr Speaker the right honorable gentleman
rightly raised the topic of National
Security because it is important but
this is
make a great prime minister
let's let's remember Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker let's remember that National
Security agenda abolishing our Armed
Forces scrapping the nuclear deterrent
withdrawing from NATO voting against
every single anti-terror law we try
befriending Hamas and Hezbollah he may
want to forget about it but we will
remind him of it every week because
there's the conservative government that
will keep this country safe